i know we've had a couple of hiccups but
this time it's a hundred percent locked
in
i've never been so sure of anything in
my entire life
as long as i live i'm so thrilled to
share this new date with you all
here it is the new release date is
august 13th
see you all in theaters august 13th
yes ryan reynolds free guy has had quite
the journey
the first trailer debuted at new york
comic-con back in 2019.
i'm super excited to unleash this on the
world and have this open
everywhere then it was originally going
to come out july 2020. i'm not going to
be the good guy
i'm going to be the great guy okay then
december 2020 today's gonna be different
so cross your fingers that august 2021
holds
and this one we feel very good about now
to a movie that so
far hasn't moved release dates dwayne
johnson's
black adam coming this december now we
all know the rock is ripped
but cue his co-star 24 year old noah
centineo
his trainer kirk myers posted these
instagram videos of the intense workout
and there's no doubt noah is going to
live up to his character's name adam
smasher
noah's in the last stages of prep as the
movie starts filming next month
and today dwayne made another huge
casting announcement
recruiting a double-oh-seven shaken not
stood
dwayne tweets such a pleasure to
announce the final member of our justice
society
the badass statesman mr pierce brosnan
as the iconic and all-knowing dr fate
i'm grateful to have such a talented
diverse and hungry cast
hashtag black adam in other casting news
ron livingston is also joining the dc
universe
he's been cast in the upcoming flash
movie where he'll play the superhero's
dad
originally the part was given to billy
crudup but due to scheduling conflicts
with filming on the new season of apple
tv pluses the morning show
he had to bow out
you